the journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step
to lead people
follow them
if you are depressed you are living in
the past
if you are anxious you are living in the
future
if you are at peace
you are living in the present
rid of the desire to have
when i let go of what i am
i become what i might be
soft and weak winds over hard and strong
true words are not pleasant
pleasant words are not true
live for the praise of others
and you will become their prisoner
there is nothing softer and more
flexible than water
but try to resist it
watch your thoughts
they become your words
watch your words
they become your actions
watch your actions
they become your habits
watch your habits
they become your character
watch your character
it becomes your destiny
[Music]
the wise man avoids all extremes
when people know a lot
it is difficult to manage them
nature does not hurry yet everything is
accomplished
man dies from birth
knowledge is the treasure
and practice is the key to it
who knows doesn't say
who speaks
doesn't know
he who is satisfied with his lot is rich
whoever talks a lot
often fails
life is a series of natural and
spontaneous changes
don't resist them
that only creates sorrow
let reality be reality
let things flow naturally forward in
whatever way they like
victory over others gives strength
victory over oneself gives fearlessness
do not seek
otherwise you will lose
do not seek
and you will find
a man dies easily because he has too
much will to
live time is a created thing
to say i don't have time is like saying
i don't want to
fill your bowl to the brim and it will
spill
keep sharpening your knife
and it will be blunt
the one who knows and pretends not to
know is on top
who without knowledge pretends to be
knowledgeable
he is sick
care about what other people think
and you will always be their prisoner
even a loss can turn into a profit
or profit can turn into a loss
there is no crime greater than having
too many desires
there is no disaster greater than not
being content
there is no misfortune greater
than being covetous
be attentive to your thoughts
they are the beginning of actions
you can always rise above those who
offend you
by forgiving them
the truth is not always beautiful
nor are beautiful words the truth
you are controlled by the one who makes
you angry
be content with what you have
rejoice in the way things are
when you realize there is nothing
lacking
the whole world belongs to you
never say
never
because the days go by so fast
and nothing stays the same
we gain by losing
lose by gaining
when i free myself from who i am
i become who i can be
temperance is the first step of virtue
which is the beginning of moral
perfection
the snow goose needs not bathe to make
itself white
neither need you do anything but be
yourself
the wise man is one who knows what he
does not know
if you lack faith then existence does
not believe in you
what the caterpillar calls the end
the rest of the world calls a butterfly
have just three things to teach
simplicity
patience
compassion
these three are your greatest treasures
being deeply loved by someone gives you
strength
while loving someone deeply gives you
courage
new beginnings are disguised as painful
endings
so the unwilling soul sees what's hidden
and the ever wanting soul sees only what
it wants
be bent and you will stay straight
be empty and you will remain complete
be worn out
and you will stay new
health is the greatest possession
contentment is the greatest treasure
confidence is the greatest friend
the whole being knows without learning
sees without looking
and attains without doing
success is as dangerous as failure hope
is as hollow as fear
people of higher morality do not
consider themselves moral
therefore they have the highest morality
a sage who wants to be above people puts
himself below them
wanting to be ahead of them he becomes
behind
what is a good man but a bad man's
teacher
what is a bad man but a good man's job
if you are alone for a long time
soon you will accept loneliness
you will never know your potential if
you are afraid to be alone
because one believes in oneself
one doesn't try to convince others
because one is content with oneself one
doesn't need others approval
because one accepts oneself the whole
world accepts him or her
by remaining true to yourself without
seeking to compare and compete
you will achieve universal respect
a man with outward courage dares to die
a man with inner courage
dares to live
a great man clings to the essential and
leaves the insignificant
he does everything in truth but
he will never rely on laws
if you aren't afraid of dying
there is nothing you can't achieve
whoever undertaking a business hurries
too quickly to achieve a result will do
nothing
he who carefully finishes his work
as he began
will not fail
true virtue is lost
good nature appears
when good nature is lost
justice appears
when justice is lost
decency
appears the rules of decency are only
the semblance of truth
and the beginning of all disorder
[Music]
to recognize your insignificance is
empowering
he who knows the measure is satisfied
with his position
sometimes you must yield in order to win
and sometimes maintaining a low place
leads you to win
we have collected these quotes from lao
zoo which reflect the wisdom of chinese
philosophy and in our opinion will
become immortal rules for many
generations teaching people to take the
right path in life thanks for watching